A personal narrative is a true story about your life.
You write about something that has happened to you.
Pre-writing is what you do before you write your story.
You make a plan for your writing.
You think about what will go on each page you write.
I have already brainstormed and chosen a topic for my story.
So now I'm ready to plan and pre-write.
I'm going to write about when I got my new dog.
So, first I need to think about what important things happened...
...that I'm going to write about.
I have four pages, so I'm going to think about...
...what will go on each page.
The first thing that happened was my mom told me I could get a dog.
Then we went to the store because they have some dogs...
...that needed to be adopted.
Next, we looked at all the dogs and we chose the one that we wanted.
And then last, we got the dog some food and some toys on our way home.
So now, I have a plan for my story.
When I'm ready to write my draft,...
...I can look at my plan to remember what to write on each page.